ryomen sukuna is perhaps the strongest
sorcerer in history and during his
Heyday 1 000 years ago he went from just
a human sorcerer to the king of curses
he went from a mere mortal to a cursed
God how did he do it what are his
world-breaking powers and abilities and
what is his true master plan right now
in the modern world there's a reason why
sukuna Soul was split into 20 cursed
objects and there's a reason why sukuna
reappeared right now in the modern era
by the end of this video you will learn
everything you need to know about
sukuna's dark Origins his unbelievable
demonic powers and his true intentions
for the modern world you guys know how
this works if you enjoy our Jujutsu
Kaizen content and you want us to keep
it coming leave a quick like and comment
right now to help us out with that
YouTube algorithm and if you watch my
videos but you haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet we are trying to hit 2
million subscribers right now so every
subscription counts and it helps us out
a lot okay so suku now originally lived
During the heian period of Japanese
history which took place about 1 000
years ago this is a real historical
period in our own world but in the world
of Jujutsu Kaizen this period is known
as the Golden Age of sorcery that is
because cursed energy was most abundant
during this period meaning that there
were a lot of extremely powerful
Sorcerers and extremely powerful curses
that were running around at that time
fun fact but in Demon Slayer both the
demons and the demon Slayers Trace their
Origins to the heian era as well clearly
this period of History which took place
between 794 and
1185 A.D is associated with mythical and
magical power and this makes sense as
the heian period was seen as a golden
age of Japanese culture a period in
which Japan began asserting its own
independent identity after years of
being strongly influenced by the older
larger and more powerful Chinese
civilization now some believe that
sukuna is even older than the heian
period because during the heian era he
was already considered a demon dubbed
the king of curses sukuna's true form at
that time was described as having four
arms and two faces clearly he was no
longer just human at this point so he
may have actually been born much earlier
that said we do know that during the
heian period sukuna murdered many
powerful Jujutsu Sorcerers and no matter
how many Sorcerers tried to defeat him
they all failed sukuna became so
notorious that people began believing
that he was actually a demon all along
and that he might have always been a
powerful cursed Spirit who was created
by the human fear of demons however in
Chapter 3 of the the manga Gojo confirms
that sukuna was in fact a human once and
we know that he still possesses memories
of when he was human During the heian
period sukuna apparently managed to
single-handedly destroy the strongest
sorcerer groups at that time including
the sun moon stars and the five empty
generals these were the most elite
Sorcerers of the fujiwara clan which was
the most powerful clan in Japan at that
time the fujiwara clan did also exist in
our own world and they were said to be
essentially the true political and
military power in Japan at that time
technically the ruler was the emperor
and the Imperial family but the fujiwara
clan was the true power base and they
regularly intermarried with the Imperial
family in order to secure their position
on top I guess this situation is similar
to the Tokugawa shogunate of the Edo
period where again the emperor was
technically the ruler but the real power
rested with the Shogun long story short
back then sukuna was an absolute Menace
who struck fear into even the most
powerful sorcerer families in Japan and
although he was once a human sorcerer he
eventually became the evil king of
curses known as the disgraced one but
why did sukuna become evil and how did
he attain an inhuman form despite
starting out as human we obviously don't
have every detail of sukuna's life story
but from what we know about him it's
safe to assume that he is motivated by
an unrelenting quest for power and to
become the strongest as early as chapter
3 sukuna says that any hierarchy which
is not based purely on strength is
boring and in every big battle that he
takes part in sukuna shows that he loves
the thrill of the fight he also tends to
compare humans to insects and maggots
due to the fact that they are so weak
and it is clear that he doesn't value
human life and the human will to live
for sukuna straight strength and power
are everything so someone who is weak
like a human is seen as completely
worthless in his eyes since we know that
sukuna also started out as human I
wonder what happened in his life to make
him have so much loathing for his own
species or I guess his own former
species there may be some form of
projection going on here perhaps
something tragic happened to sukuna when
he was human and because back then he
was weak he was powerless to stop it so
he decided to renounce his own Humanity
in order to become stronger and the
human insects that he sees crawling
around remind him of how weak he used to
be and that is why he hates them so much
but whatever happened to make sukuna
renounce his humanity and begin hating
humans he clearly underwent a real
transformation because despite starting
off as a normal human he somehow became
a demon-like monster with four arms
instead of two and four eyes instead of
two it's one thing for a human to do to
sorcerer to turn evil and become a
cursed user like for example suguru
ghetto but it's quite another for human
to have his body literally transform
physically until he resembles a
terrifying demon was this the result of
some sort of rare cursed technique like
makito's idle Transfiguration which
allows him to reshape souls and bodies
along with them or was it the result of
sukuna becoming so strong that he
evolved Beyond Humanity kind of like
Master Tangen or was it maybe some sort
of special flesh transformation
technique I'll talk more about this
later on in the video including my own
theory about sukuna's true final four
but in the meantime let me know how you
think sukuna came to have four arms and
four eyes instead of two down in the
comments there are some potential clues
about sukuna's true origins in real life
Japanese history and folklore although
it's mostly some pretty obscure stuff
that is not well known outside of Japan
to be honest it's hard to even find
decent English language translations of
most of this history and mythology but I
was able to dig up some stuff anyway in
the real world I'm mythological creature
known as sukuna is first mentioned in
720 A.D during the NADA period of
Japanese history the NADA period came
just before the heian period and during
this time an important text known as the
Nihon Shoki was published a book whose
title can be translated as The
Chronicles of Japan it is said to be the
second oldest recorded text in Japanese
history and basically it is a detailed
record of Japanese history up to that
point the sukuna who is mentioned in
this text has four arms and four eyes
just like the sukuna in Jujutsu Kaizen
although this sukuna also has four legs
he is said to be extremely tall over 3
meters and he is said to have superhuman
combat abilities in the Nihon Shoki
sukuna is portrayed as an evil mass
murderer who refused to submit to the
emperor's rule he is blamed for killing
tens of thousands of people in his
violent opposition to the emperor anyway
was only defeated after the emperor sent
his Shogun take furukuma no Mikoto to
kill him so he is basically a demonic
superhuman Warrior who killed thousands
and rebelled against the emperor he is a
symbol of evil violence and chaos but
here's the interesting part this is not
the only type of portrayal of sukuna in
Japanese folklore according to the Nihon
choki sukuna was from hida Province and
that is where he staged his evil
Rebellion but some locals in what was
once Hita Province actually venerate and
worship sukuna as a benevolent Guardian
to this day far from being a demonic
murderer he was credited with
introducing Buddhism to the province and
he was said to protect the people from
Monsters such as evil dragons some have
even referred to him as an incarnation
of the bodhisattva Canon and if you know
anything about Japanese Buddhism then
you know that this is some of the
highest praise possible Soul how can
this happen how can ryoming sukuna be a
murderous demon According to some and
the benevolent protector and spiritual
Guardian according to others one theory
is that the real life sukuna was one of
hida province's local rulers who pushed
for Independence and tried to resist the
rule of the emperor because the Nihon
Shoki was put together by the Imperial
family sukuna was portrayed as a demonic
villain because he dared to stand up
against the emperor's divine right to
rule but to the locals of hida he was
seen as someone who tried to protect
their family's property and independence
from an invading Army that sought to
subjugate them so to them sukuna was
actually a hero since the Imperial Force
has won in the end their portrayal of
sukuna as evil is what stuck history is
written by The Victors and that is what
we find in most modern depictions of
sukuna in media but as I said some
locals in what was once either Province
still see sukuna as a hero and
benevolent Guardian which is why they
worship and venerate him this is
extremely interesting and to me this
begs the question since we know that
there are two sides I.E two faces to the
real life sukuna could something similar
also be happening in Jujutsu Kaizen is
sukuna really just a sadistic monster
who sees all humans as worthless insects
or could there be more to his story
could it be that back when he was human
he was actually a hero who tried to
protect others and then a tragic series
of events led him to transform into a
human-hating monster what if sukuna was
a local ruler who tried to protect his
family and his people from the invading
Imperial forces but then he lost the war
and everyone he loved was murdered by
the emperor sukuna himself managed to
survive perhaps due to the immense
cursed energy that the suffering and
death of his loved one ones produced but
he was no longer the same man he was
before with everyone he cared about now
dead he came to hate the rest of
humanity and he vowed to get revenge on
all of them he swore to never let
himself be weak and helpless again
instead he decided to become the
strongest Jujutsu sorcerer in history
now that would make for an emotional and
compelling backstory so I really hope
that something like this does really get
revealed in the end it would add so much
depth to sukuna's character but speaking
of sukuna's secret past let's talk about
his wife well to be clear there is no
evidence that tsukuna actually had a
wife and family even back when he was
human but a powerful sorceress from the
heian period does claim to be his wife I
am of course talking about yorozu a
Brash and overconfident ancient
sorceress who was obsessed with sukuna
and wanted to become his wife known for
being wild and unsophisticated yodozu
preferred to not wear any clothes Yes
you heard that right and she completely
rejected all customs and formalities she
fell in love with sukuna at First Sight
and she decided that she wanted to end
his loneliness with her love now even
though yorozu isn't exactly the most
sane and rational waifu I mean let's be
honest she's clearly a yandere it is
still interesting that upon seeing
sukuna in person her first impression of
him was that he was lonely this may not
mean anything or it could be a very
small hint that there is more to sukuna
in his past than just being an evil
Sorcerer And the king of curses maybe he
really was different ones long ago and
that is why he seemed so lonely now that
he's forsaken his Humanity another
powerful sorcerer that sukuna has a
direct connection to is the most
important villain in the entire story so
far and the Chief Architect of
everything that's been happening
introduce to Kaizen up to this point
kenjaku kenjaku was the one who turned
sukuna's fingers into cursed objects
allowing sukuna to survive from the
heian period all the way up to today
presumably sukuna willingly made a
contract with kanjaku in order to make
this happen and that is why sukuna's
vessel Yuji was automatically entered
into the culling game once the culling
game began we don't know the exact
details of how this contract came to be
but since we know that sukuna was a more
powerful sorcerer than kenjaku it is
likely that kenjaku turned tsukuna's
fingers into cursed objects because that
is exactly what sukuna wanted him to do
the big question is why did sukuna just
want to ensure that he will Live Forever
by turning his fingers into cursed
objects and then using those cursed
objects to possess new vessels for all
of eternity or was there some specific
reason why sukuna wanted to live long
enough to be present in this particular
period of history is there something in
the modern world that sukuna is
especially interested in we all know
that kanjaku has a crazy master plan for
all of pan and frankly the entire world
but what exactly is sukuna planning the
king of curses isn't the type of guy who
would just blindly follow the whims of
kanjaku so what is he really after that
is the million dollar question and in
order to understand sukuna's true
intentions we have to take a closer look
at all of his unique powers and
abilities sukuna possesses superhuman
strength speed agility and endurance and
even without cursed techniques he is a
master of hand-to-hand combat he is also
extremely intelligent and tactically
Brilliant allowing him to be extremely
effective in any battle his intellect
allows him to attain full Mastery of his
cursed techniques and reverse cursed
energy making him a practically
insurmountable Force he is especially
dangerous because he possesses
unbelievably vast levels of cursed
energy and in fact sukuna may have more
cursed energy than any other being in
history we know for a fact that sukuna
has a lot more cursed energy at his
disposal than even satoru Gojo but Gojo
is able to use the cursed energy that he
does have extremely efficiently due to
the six eyes which is what allows Gojo
to hold his own against sukuna without
running out of cursed energy even other
cursed energy behemoths like Utah are
simply no match for sukuna when it comes
to sheer quantity of curse energy Utah
believes that sukuna may have at least
doubled the amount of cursed energy that
he does if not more on top of having
insane amounts of cursed energy sukunai
is also highly effective at controlling
his cursed energy which can often be
just as important as having a lot of it
if you don't have excellent control of
your cursed energy even if you have a
lot of it it will leak out inefficiently
and it will be wasted very quickly being
able to control and manipulate your
cursed energy in an effective and
efficient way is extremely important
according to Hajime kashimo if Gojo
didn't have the six eyes sukuna would be
even more effective in controlling his
cursed energy than Gojo luckily for Gojo
the extremely rare technique known as
the six eyes allows him to stand
toe-to-toe with sukuna now we don't know
for sure what sukuna's original curse
technique is because he demonstrates the
ability to use two distinct types of
attacks the first is the ability to
launch invisible cuts and slashes at his
opponents and the second is the ability
to launch Firebase attacks at his
opponents such as fire arrows as
mentioned earlier sukunai is also able
to use reverse curse technique which
allows him to heal his injuries
extremely quickly including very serious
injuries like lost limbs sukuna also
possesses the extremely rare ability to
heal the bodies of others using his
reverse curse technique and he can even
use it to heal his own burnt out curse
technique which is another incredibly
rare ability sukuna is able to use
domain amplification which is an
anti-domain technique that allows sukuna
to envelop himself in his own domain in
order to resist the curse technique and
domain expansion of his opponent and
speaking of the main expansion sukuna's
domain is called malevolent Shrine and
it is one of the absolutely strongest
domains in the history of Jujutsu kaisen
when sukuna expands his domain a dark
and creepy Buddhist Shrine appears
behind him the shrine is surrounded by
water and its foundation seems to be
made on top of a whole bunch of animal
skulls that may belong to Bulls the
shrine also has a bunch of giant horns
that might also be bull horns growing
out of the roof the engine says to the
shrine on each of the four sides look
like giant mouths with tea overall I
have to say that malevolent Shrine is
probably the coolest domain expansion
visually it is equal parts epic and
creepy and the color scheme of the Blue
Water beneath and the red clouds above
is just Next Level I would absolutely
wear a malevolent Shrine T-shirt If I
ever got the chance anyway this domain's
guaranteed hit attack is a ruthless and
continuous slashing attack that will
tear apart everything inside the domain
except for sukuna himself there are two
types of slashing attacks cleave and
dismantle and the attacks will continue
until sukunai's weakened to the point
that he can no longer maintain his own
domain cleave is sukuna's Attack of
choice for enemies who possess cursed
energy while dismantle is used to
destroy inanimate objects due to its
ability to unleash a barrage of endless
slashing attacks malevolent Shrine is
essentially a weapon of mass destruction
it can kill hundreds of civilians and
destroy an endless number of objects
within a 200 meter radius almost
instantly sukuna is able to control the
range of his domain within certain
parameters and he is able to expand his
domain without actually closing the
barrier he uses a binding vial to create
an escape route from his domain in
exchange for the ability to expand the
effective range of his guaranteed hits
since malevolent Shrine doesn't have an
outer barrier you cannot destroy the
domain just by destroying the barrier
the only way to destroy the domain is to
injure sukuna so severely that he can no
longer maintain it and as you can
imagine having to inflict such serious
injuries on the strongest sorcerer in
history is no easy task in addition
sukuna is able to actually change the
conditions of his domain using a binding
vowel and this allows him to do do
things like remove the domains
guaranteed hit effect in order to
increase the domain's overall power
along with unlimited void malevolent
Shrine is the most sophisticated domain
expansion in all of Jujutsu kaisen and
any clash between these two domains
really is a battle of the gods I don't
want to spoil too much of the story for
those of you who are not caught up to
the manga but we do get to see both
sukuna and malevolent Shrine in Action a
lot more as the story progresses and
it's safe to say that sukuna's full
power is absolutely terrifying and
exhilarating at the same time finally
let's talk about sukuna's ability to
transform his flesh because this little
power might end up being a lot more
important than we realize we first see
this ability manifesting once Yuji
consumes suguna's fingers and becomes
his vessel even though Yuji is able to
maintain control of his body for the
most part and he successfully prevents
sukuna from taking over sukuna is still
able to manifest a mouth and eyes on
yuji's body and he can use them to see
and speak he is able to do this against
the hosts well without having to
actually take over the body from the
hopes this ability to transform his
flesh could be an important clue about
sukuna's true form and why he looked so
differently back during the heian period
assuming that he really was human ones
sukuna would have been born with two
arms and two eyes and yet in his true
form or final form back at the height of
his power he had four arms four eyes and
his face looked drastically different
from that of a normal human face it is
possible that sukunai used his ability
to transform his flesh in order to
attain this optimal final form which he
became known for and if that is the case
then we can expect tsukuna to try to
attain this form again in the modern
world the fact that he still hasn't
attained this form suggests that he is
still not at full power even though
right now in the manga he is absolutely
in incredibly powerful infinitely more
powerful than he was at the beginning of
the story perhaps when he finally
consumes that 20th finger sukuna will
regain his forearmed form and that is
when he will finally be at his Peak once
again after 1 000 years so is this
sukuna's ultimate master plan to regain
his full power and his true form in the
modern world and if so why did he have
Kendrick who turn him into a cursed
object just because he wanted to live as
long as possible and because he wanted
to be reincarnated into some distant
more interesting time period or could
there be some reason why sukuna wanted
to return during this specific period of
time is the sukuna of Jujutsu Kaizen
just a one-dimensional evil sadist or
could there be some Nuance to his
character like with the real sukuna who
is hated and feared by some but honored
and revered by others was yorozu's
observation that sukuna seems lonely a
clue that he did have a different life
once but it was taken away from him
could sukunas re-emergence in the modern
world have something to do with the
evolution of Master tengen who has
continued to evolve Beyond Humanity for
these past 1 000 years we know that
kanjaku has a place for tengen in his
master plan but kutsukuna also be
interested in tengin's evolution if
sukuna really was a normal human once
and if he became a monster after
something precious was taken away from
him such as perhaps his family then
maybe he believes that once Master
tengan becomes powerful enough he will
be able to use tengen to correct the
injustices that he suffered all those
centuries ago maybe sukuna believes that
tengen can bring back his family or some
other precious thing that was taken away
from him as cool as it is to have a
merciless and Unapologetic Villain Like
sukuna I Do personally hope that there
is more Nuance to him and that it all
goes back to his true backstory I also
hope that tsukuna has a secret master
plan that goes beyond just being a tool
for kanjaku and this secret master plan
could change everything we thought we
knew about sukuna tengen and the Very
nature of jujutsu's sorcery let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
below does sukuna have a tragic
backstory that we still don't know about
and does he have a secret master plan
that required him to return in this
specific time period If you're looking
for an epic jiu Jutsu Kaizen video to
watch next don't ignore my video on how
sukuna's biggest Rivals satoru Gojo
became an absolute monster Link in the
description and on screen right now if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like to let me know and if you're one of
the over 50 of people who watch my
videos but haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a big favor and
subscribe right now we are trying to
level this channel up to special grade
by hitting 2 million subscribers and
every single subscription counts